bonsoir messieurs merci d'être avec nous
pour ce débat l'assemblée nationale
adopte donc définitivement le pass
vaccinale pierre-henri bovy qu'est ce
que cette adoption nous dit sur la
stratégie du gouvernement et sur ces
prises de position
coup tu es déjà se passe dax inhalent à
mon sens est plus impasse politique qui
a un pass vaccinale l'évolution en des
milk du virus confirmée par la baisse
dès la minute de réanimation pour à mon
sens l'inutilité de ce bad vaccinale qui
est plus justifiée pour décor par des
considérations politiques puisque je
vous rappelle nous sommes dans campagne
présidentielle que par une véritable
nécessité de santé publique
claude movie vous êtes d'accord avec
pierre envie bovy ce qu'il s'agit
l'impasse politique plutôt qu'un pass
vaccinale impasse sanitaires
je suis assez d'accord en fait parce que
autant le pass maximale aurait été utile
il y a quelques mois parce que la
vaccination des plus à risques est
vraiment quelque chose qu'il fallait
faire autant au jour d'aujourd'hui c'est
beaucoup moins nécessaire mais comme
toujours le politique a souvent un peu
de retard sur le
sur ce qu'il faut faire raisonnablement
est effectivement le gouvernement a fait
le choix de monter au créneau sur ce que
la population pense quand même
majoritairement être une bonne chose et
donc je suis assez d'accord que ce
n'était pas le moment d'obliger tout le
monde assure vacciner parce que tout ce
qui devait être vaccinés le sont en tout
cas la plupart d'entre eux est ce qu'ils
ne sont pas et qui devrait l'être
c'est-à-dire les plus âgés ceux qui sont
les plus fragiles ceux qui sont
particulièrement malades s'ils ne le
sont pas aujourd'hui je crains que ce ne
soit pas le pas ce qui les amènera ce
maxi n'est alors qu'ils devraient
absorber bovy une soixantaine de députés
annoncent saisir le conseil
constitutionnel
vis-à-vis de ce pass se passer vaccinale
vous pensez que les sages pourraient
être en mesure vont pouvoir retoqué
retoqué se passer vaccinale en tout cas
là on peut se féliciter yon ka on peut
être rassuré ce que des magistrats comme
veille aussi à l'action à l'action
politique et veille aussi à ce que nos
libertés et nos droits ne soient pas non
plus totalement empiéter puisque le
problème avec cette crise sanitaire
c'est depuis maintenant de longs mois on
s'habitue si vous voulez une situation
exceptionnelle une situation de crise
qui ont été de lundi situation
permanente l'exceptionnel devient le
permanent et la situation d'urgence
devient réalité une situation tout à
fait banal devient et une banalisation
des restrictions qui sont en train
d'être fait surtout une banalisation à
mon sens de mesures totalement auto et
autoritaire et arbitraire qui qui sont
prises j'entendais notamment des
politiques qui avaient votre quid ans
quand même de proposer la suppression
des allocations chômage pour les
personnes non vaccinées j'ai entendu
dire aussi des personnes qui devait être
mise au banc en réalité d'assises de la
société celle qui n'étaient pas vaccinés
c'est à dire qu on perds un peu les
pédales sur sur cette crise et je pense
tout beaucoup de politiques aujourd'hui
sur fond peut-être de calcul politique
en tout cas n'hésite pas à renier sur
les libertés fondamentales sur les
droits des français sous un faux
prétexte de santé publique on voit bien
de toute manière que le vaccin et je
m'en remettrai à mon contradicteur mais
on voit bien que le vaccin aujourd'hui
n'empêche pas à la circulation du virus
est donc bien que ce pass axe inhalent
neyrand éviter qu'un pas ce qui va
permettre de polariser la société
déplacer la société dans deux catégories
celles qui seront vaccinés non vaccinés
donc c'est à dire en plus qu'il ya une
atteinte à mon sens sont plus au secret
médical et va empêcher des personnes
vous l'avez dire en introduction va
empêcher des citoyens d'accéder
ad des restaurants à des salles prendre
le train et c'est un je ne sais pas dans
quelle société quelle société nous
promet premier aujourd'hui les
politiques qui nous gouvernent
actuellement à claude bronner
la ministre espagnole de la santé
envisage de considérer le kobe 19 comme
une maladie endémique
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
estime que ce n'est pas à coups de dose
de rappel qu'on mettra fin à la pandémie
et pourtant le gouvernement français
s'entête à poursuivre sa politique
sanitaire à mettre en place ce pass
vaccinale alors qu'on le sait omicron
est moins dangereux que lé précédent
variant mais qu'est-ce que quelque part
le gouvernement français n'est pas en
train et bien sans tête vis-à-vis de ce
pass vaccinale pour ne pas perdre la
face
je pense que c'est exactement la
situation et s'est intéressé très
intéressant que l'espagne ait pris cette
décision je crois qu'ils sont pas en
période électorale eux et c'est vraiment
dommage c'est dommage qu'on n'ait pas su
prendre le virage parce que il est vrai
qu'il y a quelques mois la très très
grande majorité des médecins et je ne
parle même pas de ceux qui qui travaille
à l'hôpital qui est vraiment voir venir
les cas graves auraient applaudi des
deux mains aujourd'hui je dois bien sur
le terrain les médecins sont comme comme
les patients il voit qu'effectivement le
vaccin n'empêche pas le virus de
circuler il voit qu'au micro et moins
dangereux ils voient que les
hospitalisations monte encore mais mais
que ça va se calmer et que les
réanimations baisse déjà donc on voit
bien que la réalité médicale en fait à
rattraper le gouvernement dans son
calendrier et je suis je suis vraiment
un peu déçu et qu'il n'ait pas été
capable de prendre le virage est en fait
là on prend une décision qui est à
contre courant elle ne durera pas
éternellement parce qu'effectivement
autour de nous ça va changer c'est
vraiment pas une décision
qui qui est politiquement intelligente
en ce moment parce que le calendrier du
virus n'arrange pas du tout sur les buts
et du gouvernement en fait c'est ça la
réalité le virus est en train de mettre
le choix politiques abba en montrant à
toute la population que c'était pas ça
qu'il fallait faire mais pour le moment
il ya une majorité qui est pour qu'on
oblige qui est pour qu'on force ça va
durer encore un petit moment alors
dorénavant il faudra donc pouvoir
justifier d'un statut vaccinal pour
accéder aux activités de loisirs
restaurants bars foire ou transports
publics inter-régionaux donc ces cinq
millions de français non vaccinés qui
vont donc rester au ban de la société
la devise la france ont cessé liberté
égalité fraternité pierre-henri body est
ce que la devise française n'est pas
aujourd'hui quelque peu abîmée
vous disiez justement 5 millions de
citoyens qui sont mis au ban ce ne sont
même plus des citoyens d'ailleurs si on
en croit le président de la république
peu près dans la public à doké que ce ne
serait que ce n'était plus des citoyens
ce n'était pas un acte ii en tout cas de
citoyenneté de ne pas se faire vacciner
on marche complètement sur la tête là ce
qui ce qu'il faut bien retenir c'est
qu'effectivement l'état doit assurer un
devoir d'assurer la sécurité sanitaire
des citoyens mais il ya en tout cas on
la voit bien avec cette crise les
dérives autoritaires sont faciles par la
prise de position la prise de décision
un peu fantaisistes ou alors justement
qui sont attentatoires à nos libertés on
l'a bien vu sur sur des décisions sans
théistes le port du masque en extérieure
ne fonctionne pas ou du moins n'a aucune
est inutile utilité au début de la crise
ont forcé également les motards à porter
un masque sous le casque de moto on a eu
une série de décisions totalement
rocambolesque fantaisiste évidemment qui
ont été censurés par par les magistrats
par les tribunaux administratifs par le
conseil d'état heureusement qu'il ya
aussi des magistrats qui sont là pour
veiller pour garantie non respect de ces
libertés mais en tout cas ce qui est
certain c'est qu'avec ce pass vaccinale
ont c'est un plat de plus vers une
restriction toujours plus toujours plus
importante de nos libertés et pollari
polarise encore une fois encore une fois
la société
le bonheur des restrictions des libertés
de plus en plus ce succès d'un
finalement depuis deux ans maintenant
est ce que sanitairement parlant vous en
tant que médecin vous jugez se passe
vaccinale nécessaire et vous pensez
qu'il est
qui va servir véritablement à empêcher
la propagation du virus et à convaincre
les français est réfractaire à se faire
vacciner
je crois qu'on l'a déjà largement abordé
la réponse est clairement non le pass
vaccinale n'y changera rien ce qu'il
faudrait faire c'est vacciner les plus à
risque qui ne le sont pas mais c'est pas
le pas ce qu'ils valent et les obligés
parce que parce qu'ils l'ont fait je
prendrai mon cas particulier je suis
médecin donc je ne peux pas travailler
si je ne suis pas vacciné je suis
bientôt à la limite que je vais devoir
faire la troisième dose de l'aco vie
depuis mulhouse qui qui m'a fait le
rappel et je n'ai pas peur du vaccin je
m'en fiche je le ferai mais vraiment
vraiment médicalement ça me fâche d'être
obligé de me faire un vaccin qu'il
faudrait faire en fait à peu près toutes
les dix semaines pour atteindre le le
maximum de ce que nous montre la science
en fait le rappel si vous voulez
vraiment être au maximum de la
protection c'est pratiquement toutes les
dix semaines qu'il faut faire a rappelé
donc ça on peut le faire pour un patient
très très à risque mais pour le
tout-venant ça n'a pas de sens et je
suis personnellement tout à fait fâché
d'être obligé de me vacciner alors que
je n'ai pas envie et que médicalement
j'ai pas de raison et la seule chose que
j'accepterai à la limite c'est qu'on me
dise comme vous avez plus de 65 ans ou
plus de 60 ans
si vous vous retrouvez en ré à vous
payer une partie de votre poche ça je
trouverais que c'est à peu près la seule
chose que personnellement je trouverais
normal pour ceux qui ne veulent pas se
vacciner mais mais autrement je trouve
ça n'a pas de sens et c'est ça n'a pas
de sens parce que la situation médicale
a évolué et heureusement d'ailleurs je
voudrais dire aussi que je suis quand
même reconnaissant à mon gouvernement
d'avoir été moins pire que d'autres il y
à des pays où ça a été encore bien pire
que chez nous on a pas eu d confinement
comme d'autres à des moments où ce
n'était probablement moins nécessaire
ce que les confinements ça diminue un
petit peu les patients en réhab les ca
d'autres inconvénients et beaucoup de
problèmes médicaux médicaux par ailleurs
donc ça a été plutôt bien géré le ce
côté là et là on est en train de d'aller
dans le mauvais sens à mon sens à
pierre-henri bovy pour terminer alors
plusieurs voix s'élèvent pour dénoncer
un système de crédit social est la
chinoise qui est bien arriverait en
france et qui pourrait durer dans le
temps c'est une de vos craintes
également
c'est exactement ce que je vous disais
en introduction c'est que le régime
d'exception devient régime de droit
commun à l'exceptionnelle devient le
permanent et et lorsqu on vous retire
une liberté ou du moins lorsqu'on
empiète sur des droits des droits
fondamentaux et lorsque justement on y
arrive il est très difficile de revenir
en arrière donc évidemment il faut
veiller à ce que ces libertés ses droits
fondamentaux soient préservés et
notamment d'ailleurs au premier titre
puisque on parle de crise sanitaire le
secret médical puisque quand même avec
cette crise on a failli le mental à mon
sens financier au secret médical puisque
aujourd'hui une des premières questions
qu'on pose d'ailleurs et les dents sur
beaucoup de plateau se demander aux
invités s'ils sont vaccinés s'ils ont
fait leur troisième dose leur deuxième
dose externe ça le regarde personne ça
ne devrait concerner que celui qui est
justement concernés par cette troisième
dose par ce deuxième dose par ce vaccin
et on doit encore avoir le choix une
chance de se faire vacciner ou non
eh bien ça sera le mot de la fin à
pierre henri bouvier merci d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes à beauvau ko au barreau de
paris merci à vous également claude
bronner médecin généraliste à strasbourg
vice président du syndicat union
généraliste